okay hello everyone welcome to the
latest in our season of design reviews
getting ready for wolfgang language
version 13.
and first one we have today
is a continuation about graph theory i
think or maybe it's geometry geometry
and graphics
okay fine all right
so let's see we had been looking
previously
has this been updated
yeah
that's the new name we came up with
okay all right
then the next two gradient mesh was
called poisson mesh
and the ball mesh was called
concave hull mesh
were those the names we agreed on last
time no
kind of like gradient mesh or at least
something like it
what does it mean oh i mean
oh there's also the chance of gradient
fit mesh because we are fitting the
gradient
and that will be ball fed mesh
yes all concave feet mesh because you
know concave is no way
okay
we're not comforting con cavities
we're fitting
what about other meshes aren't other
meshes also fits
what other meshes do we have i mean the
lawn eye mesh from points is dylon mesh
and voronoi mesh
and
they
they're duels but they also have a
geometric construction from the start
voronoi is basically an optimization
description it's the nearest description
yeah
but but now i guess those aren't neither
of those are mesh reconstruction methods
yes they are
yeah
well they are but last time they are
yes they are
well like if it's like you have a mesh
and you sample a bunch of points from it
you know
these other reconstruction methods all
are supposed to give you those meshes
back these give you a different mesh
they're just functions from points to
meshes
what was the name we came up with last
time we came up with something
reconstruction mesh right
what was the name for for the future
reconstruction
mesh
it is the idea that like in the future
there'll be a big function that just
does these automatically and maybe has
other methods too
yeah right we can we can't do that now
but we can do that in the future
and because also reconstruction is kind
of the ill post problem right i mean
it's you know it's
so we need you know that general
function will have a lot of rustic it
needs it needs goals what's the goal of
the reconstruction
i mean i would argue
it's not just representatives
do the same thing they're different
goals should it be closed well it should
be construction yeah right but it has
certain properties it's not going to be
able to necessarily do a perfect
reconstruction whether i assume i can
look for bull mash says
where is it sorry can i find this please
where is it
yes
i i would argue that there's still a
division between something like delano
mesh or
especially voronoi mesh and these other
reconstruction things because they're
not reconstructing anything they're just
constructing something
you're right christopher
but
but
there is a goal okay what's the goal of
constructing a voronoi mesh
it's a different goal than some other
goals
for sure
and if you look at reconstruction
mesh i mean the you know we kind of
start to explicitly document those
different goal and constraint
so you need kind of a language to
describe what you want at the end
i have a spelling mistake then
reconstruction
um
okay but so
okay
okay this is a crazy thing to say i mean
either we're saying
you grow a ball from every point is that
the correct thing is that what it's
actually doing
what is it actually doing
well because one thing
you know you could end up with sort of a
balloon dog type thing right where you
just grow in a puffy ball from every
point
that's is that what this is or is that
not what this is no so like you see here
it's just roughly speaking if you think
about it like a sub half of the dolan
image so you have it on image
and then essentially giving a you know
a ball of fredo's alpha you see if those
edge
of the delaney mesh fits inside that
ball and then it's those edges you're
actually picking
okay i absolutely do not believe in this
title in this name ball mesh then i
absolutely profoundly do not believe in
it because i would expect a balloon dog
well no no it's equivalent okay maybe
the balloon dog is a different thing but
it's equivalent to if you grow a ball
from each vertex where you know and you
select all the you know you you draw you
you only keep the delano edges to other
points that are within that ball right
but what i would expect for a ball mesh
is a mesh made from a bunch of spheres
right we could imagine doing that that
would be a perfectly reasonable thing to
do right imagine no
mesh is piecewise linear
well i don't care i mean
it's
what i do a region union of a bunch of
balls but it usually is kind of
not very not useful it's not useful
right but i just don't think that's the
right name because i think it suggests
things are going to be made from balls
okay and your piecewise linearity
statement about meshes is a very
parochial statement
i mean i don't know go ahead this was
kind of a temporary name and for sure
broad mesh can be ambiguous especially
that i mean there are some places
actually you know instead of generating
piecewise linear mesh you actually look
at the
same places you know curves and places
coming coming from both so there's also
that possibility in long term which can
be ambiguous okay but hold on hold on so
explain this to me again a simplex is
simplex is very well defined
what did you say
well no excuse me same places are in our
standard definition right same place yes
it's simplex
right switch is linear but there's
generalization of same places which are
not limited to linear cells which is
nice let's go through this again what
this is actually doing
okay what this is actually doing so
it is
go go ahead explain it again what it's
doing
look at the construction on the left
right yeah
so it's essentially you have a set of
points you construct the lonely mesh
right so essentially which allow you to
find the closest neighbor
right so you get those triangles pretty
much in 2d
right and then you cover those uh
triangle
with balls passing through you know two
points
and if those
edges are actually inside the balls then
you consider them so that's kind of the
illustration there
so what about something like
if it
okay but the dilemma mesh
i don't understand this you you
constructed a line triangulation
and it's kind of like the boundary the
lawn eye it's some kind of boundary of
that to low no triangulation is that
right you should you should first you
should go to the delanoy mesh
documentation so you can see what one of
them looks like
right so i mean it basically just you
know it makes it it just triangulates
all the points and and you know you just
have sort of the
right i mean you you can
this is the exterior or this in the
interior of this object is it also
triangulated or this is just the
exterior
no it's the interior that's a 2d thing
okay but what about the 3d case in which
case you have synthesis
tetrahedra
but but you're you're triangulating the
whole volume right yes yes where
interior is all filled
whereas this thing here is the boundary
of that right it is merely the surface
am i correct
uh there are cases where you can
actually have a hole inside so let's
suppose like that those set of points
are far enough that you know in the
middle there's a hole okay okay fine all
right but but but this is essentially
what you're telling me is this is
finding the boundary of the delano mesh
no correct it's not no it is not
okay
so
you are you telling me that this is
selecting certain
what from the delano mesh
certainty so imagine
certain edges right and so so imagine if
you have that delay mesh there i mean
maybe there's if there was a
documentation picture of like
points sampled from like an annulus or
taurus or something that would be great
but i don't know if there is well let's
just do it
go ahead
well i mean the point the point being if
you did it right you'd find that that
there'd be you know
there'd be all these little points along
the the actual body of the annulus and
then in the middle there'd be a couple
of giant triangles with really long
edges and so all this is doing is it's
just deleting the really long edges and
they're sort of associated triangles i
would do an annulus because it'll be
much easier to see what's going on
do we have an annulus yes we do yes okay
default annulus let's take a hundred
random points in the default annulus
and then let's say the lawn eye mesh of
that
oh for goodness sake what is that
what happened there why didn't it not do
that
hello
um
no it's a prototype probably this
there's some issue lately so probably
use the master punch
you know
i don't drink wine but that's another
place where this you know let me get a
1952
vintage whatever never mind
what the wrong vintage what's that
oh
oh i'm not drinking the right vintage
here
i see okay
never mind
right
and now i have the stupid zoom window on
top there we go
okay let's try this again here
okay there we go
i see so
and if you had even more points it'd be
even more obvious
okay all right
so now what is this thing going to do
this
it's this it's going to delete the edges
that are too long and then their
associated triangles are also going to
disappear so for example that big edge
in the middle is let's say bigger than r
it's going to delete that and it's going
to delete the two triangles on either
side of it i think
okay well so
is it in fact a filtered alumni mesh
it gave it yes you can look at it in
term of graph like you will generate
this sub curve
what is the name that's in here is it
concave whole mesh or is it ball mesh
why is it not changing color
probably needs the documentation i don't
know no
no that's not changing color either
um did we change your name
that seems to know about that
it's more modern than we are oh for
god's sake why isn't that working
okay so what would we see if this worked
we would see the same thing but without
those interior edges is that correct
no we wouldn't see the same thing we
would only see the boundary we would
just see
around the boundary right
no no it will so it will probably
delete the enter your edges like the you
know the big you know you have three
large triangles there in the middle okay
and so that will be white in that area
is that correct correct so you probably
have a pretty
right now do you have a version that
actually works we don't we don't have an
implementation of the 2d the 3d work so
i'm sure that that's probably the
problem on your builds
okay so if i do the same thing here for
taurus
that won't be a tourist but
you could do a taurus anyway
just crash the answer though is it does
keep the interior cells like i mean it
deletes certain things but it
fundamentally is keeping the interior
it's not just the boundary
okay
so really it's a filtered delany mesh is
that a true statement whatever's
happening is it's just that alumni mesh
with certain simplicities removed
correct
correct oh he used the lunar mesh to
construct
the the region
well but arguably i mean if it is
keeping all the interior stuff and maybe
it doesn't have to but then you're not
really trying to reconstruct the
original mesh because the original mesh
you know doesn't have all this interior
action right
so
the
the key is the following right so you
have you have a set of points
right your usual approach is you know
when you want to construct a you know
pull it up or polygons right you use the
convex hole
but your original set is not always
convex
right so the best way to do it is
essentially you look at close by point
right some kind of clustering and
essentially you select edges which are
close by with a certain radius
and so that's pretty much the idea so
that's why you actually cover those
points by the ball
and then yeah i understand charles
charles what i'm trying to get to is the
output if it was working correctly would
be this thing with all its little
shattered glass effect with white in the
middle am i correct or am i not correct
correct okay white in the middle correct
correct close to the annulus in 2d yes
okay fine all right with the interior
shattered glass stuff yes
yes
unlike convex hull mesh
which only shows the exterior right so
this would be completely concave mesh
will be just completely the wrong name
right because if we compare these two
right this one it really is an interior
covering mesh
with certain things deleted
right
so maybe i mean is there a fundamental
reason why it should or
why it should keep the shattered glass
stuff and why it couldn't just get the
boundary mesh
i think for many reasons it it should
it's better to keep a boundary
representation rather than a full mesh
representation
oh but
computationally
but that's not what it's doing it's
keeping the internal chatted glass right
in the current in the current
description of what you say it's doing
it's keeping that correct
yeah i mean
i think we need
but let's let's think about sort of
which is the best most useful
representation well i think they might
both be useful
i think they might both be useful too no
that's no that's not possible so that's
the that's the key thing is that you
cannot always have both representation a
boundary representation and a mess
representation
right
the technique of construction which is
specific one unless we decide to change
that technique right
essentially
you are looking at the you know the
cells in the dimension two you have the
triangles in dimension three you have
the face triangle in dimension three and
then you group them
especially on dimension three it's
obvious that you cannot actually build
it hydron so you cannot actually just
describe the boundary
are you saying it's a 2d surface in in
3d is it 2d yes all those construction
technique are purely surfaces
right wait a second wait a second wait a
second wait a second so this
reconstruction mesh
would be a surface in 3d correct or not
correct
it could be
it doesn't have to be it sounds to me
yeah the plan for a construction mesh
right since we will have the constraint
is that you can actually say you may
want a full dimensional you know a
non-empty full-dimensional region and
then we can generate you so that's why
that function will be more general and
we need okay so wait a second so this is
the point that is the point that
basically you can end up with lower
dimensional stuff because it's deleting
edges not simplices right so it's so
it's like you might delete
let's say you have a triangle if you
delete two of the edges you might end up
with a point on its own and a line on
its own and those get kept or those get
deleted or something
so you mean for which case for this con
concave hold bench or you mean yes or
for a concave home ash
um no you always get the the the cell
of the coming from the lonely mesh so
the truth
okay but so i guess
right but let's say you know you you
have three points you get there to lanai
mesh it's some trivial triangle right
um
and then and then let's say two of the
edges on that triangle are longer than
alpha and so they get deleted does that
mean that the resulting the result is
going to be an empty region or is it
going to be a point with a line or
something like that
so the star in that case is that people
say it should be an empty region
it will be an empty region like right
now without done an empty
region look okay but
so i mean how in 3d do you end up with
with triangles and not simplices
as cells or is that not
because if somebody for example sample a
sphere in 3d
right so you have a surface and then you
want to reconstruct it
it purely be that surface
okay let me make some suggestions so
what if you sample a curve into in 2d
will it be that's will will it be that
curve
well it won't be with an online mesh if
it's a if it's a filtered diloli mesh
the curve will not that look let's do it
this is what i was asking guys i mean
the question is basically if you delete
edges
right like if you if you had your curve
and you deleted all the edges that were
too long and you were just left with the
edges that go along the curve and and
those that you know
that's a that's a one-dimensional object
embedded in a 2d space and the question
is does that get deleted i think you
said the answer was yes it does
what does this do what would this do
because anything you remove here is
going to give you garbage it's not going
to give you there's no way to get
just something like the circle no no
there is because there there are edges
that go they're going along along the
perimeter so if you kept lower
dimensional stuff you would get a one
you know
a one circle or whatever
sorry say that yes i understand that
right i understand that if you keep the
lower dimensional thing but as soon as
you're keeping complete cells you're
toast here
well but you are also trying to
reconstruct a one-dimensional region
right so
what's your point
i mean if you're basically saying that
this this if this function is only for
reconstructing regions in the embedding
dimension then it's sort of like sure
then you it's understood charles is it
and how does it then relate to
reconstruction mesh which one lives only
in the embedding dimension or is it both
or is it neither
so it's both so this this this function
is just a specific technique to try to
get to a construct shape
right with this
certain hopefully certain concavity
right
no
no
let's be specific about what it is
in this case it's a pity the function
doesn't work right now
in this case
what would it do
will it remove
in this case it will reconstruct so for
a given alpha so if you know
this is the sample point of a cycle so
if you take it with a decent for a given
specific radius
you will reconstruct the circle so you
certainly know you want it
no you want there are no cells on this
boundary all the cells here are these
things that go across the diameter no no
no no no no so
right so you have this a random so you
have your sample hand you know circle
uniformly
and essentially you know between those
circles
the dynamesh actually connected the bond
away
plus you have those launchers but those
angles but hold on hold on so you're
claiming on the boundary here
can i say boundary mesh of this will i
get the boundary yes yes
it'll just be a convex hull though
so what is that is that a single is that
is that a single mesh i i think there's
a bigger one that says the boundary mesh
of the mesh is the convex hull so that
is the convex cell
boundary mesh works generally
yeah you want john boundary right is
what you want
if you just want the boundary you get
region boundary so that applies to
general regions not just meshes
okay so region boundary of percent four
okay there we go all right so that
you're telling me those are a bunch of
little micro cells is that correct yeah
a line segment is a cell
no point but is it a cell in the right
number of dimensions
that's the question is it a cell
within dimension two
or not because what we're saying is this
function is selecting cells in the
embedding dimension
no i think that this is where we got
confused no
no
what charles said if you're going to
reconstruct a surface in 3d
you know a surface is not of dimension
three it's of dimension two yeah it's
not the same as the embedding dimension
okay
and the curve okay so
you're totally confusing me this thing
here you told me that your ball mesh
construct well that's what is confused
thing because it's it's
in this
reconstructs the same dimension as the
embedding dimension so that's so we got
to decide because either it's not hard
so so you see is that the annulus have
an interior right so if you sample the
point you simply understand how to enter
your point right so it'll be possible to
reconstruct the triangle inside the
interior
where in the case of your circle there
right the circle doesn't have interior
points so that's why you have those long
edges connecting to the other side so
for a given alpha you will not be able
to carry those edges so you end up with
you know just the way
so this coarsened
delano mesh
can return things which are not in the
mesh is that correct
which are not in the full dimensional
mesh is that correct or not
no
okay
then how is it returning would okay
would those line segments are in the
mesh steven those line segments are in
the mesh above
so the mesh contains things of different
dimension yes correct well although we
did say something i think about like
well okay never mind i think with
highlight graph we talked about vertices
and edges aren't so
same
you take that mesh and then you say mesh
cell or mesh count we give you all the
cells from dimension zero one two three
at least one here
if i say measure
how do i do this is it matches count
mesh cell or missile account yes
account account maybe i misunderstood
earlier but i thought you were saying
that
this is the number
of cells of dimension zero
uh one
okay okay but i i i thought you said
earlier that and maybe i misunderstood
but i thought you were saying that that
it will delete things that are a lower
demand it will delete all the cells that
are at uh a lower dimension in the
embedding dimension or at least like if
there's a line you know if you do this
annulus thing and then you delete those
interior cells but there's also this
line segment that just goes off to the
side right just a lone edge that's not
part of a triangle my impression was
that that edge was going to get deleted
or is that not correct
right because if it is going to get
deleted then you're just ending up with
a bunch of triangles you're only going
to have you know you're only preserving
this the
cells that contribute to a cell that's
in the embedding dimension
and and the circle case probably would
return an empty region right
is that what's right charles
i i think without being able to run this
we can't really say
when will we
when will we be able to run it
charles
um
well any version on which you can run it
right now and show us these results
right right now we you know we focus on
the 3d and the 3d should work on your
machine right so
well it didn't work
again
it crashed
no no so that was taught us you know we
are working on adding or sound on
pointers in your photos so okay
how can i take this here
okay
okay let's take a ball here and if we
make the radius small enough we'll start
should probably take a few points i mean
it's an expensive computation
especially that in this case you haven't
specified this you know the boundary so
we need to kind of find the best
boundary to construct it okay well i
don't think this is showing me very much
other than this is showing me a kind of
a cruddy okay it looks like what's the
dimension
region so this is damage this is
dimension
three the object is dimension two right
it's just a mesh region
but i guess the question is would it be
possible that with the right inputs you
would have some line
coming off of it okay i'm just utterly
confused here this says it's a dimension
too so this is just the surface it is
not the volume
is that correct if i were to look inside
can i can i graphically go
inside
help
if i go inside
no no no that that camera model that
you're trying to use that can't go
inside that's the old one okay all right
i think if you
but it would be empty inside correct i
mean if i take a plot range and i would
see it it is there's nothing in it if i
slice it in the plot range there'd be
nothing in it correct
it's just a shell
yes
is it a boundary mesh region or a mesh
region
yeah because if if it was a boundary
mesh region it would have dimension
three
here
okay sure
so the idea is that essentially when you
have a set of points right you tend to
want to reconstruct the surface
right is because i mean when you have an
object you can essentially sample the
surface
right
and if you want it but it doesn't seem
consistent oh wait a minute we don't
have it in in 2d
you know because it does should do the
same
because we were running the lonnie mesh
we looked they didn't look at that that
was the mesh right so yeah so we go
if we ran it correctly what we would see
here is none of the i asked you three
times do you see the shattered glass in
the interior and you said yes but
actually the answer is no is that
correct
and what we would see instead is just
the
exterior
and we would just see a thing that looks
like the annulus without any shattered
glass it would contain the interior
boundary and the exterior boundary
correct
is that correct or not
so the the i think the fundamental you
know confusion here there's no confusion
i'm asking a very specific question i
want to know if this function was
working correctly would i see this
interior shattered glass or not or would
you instead look like okay so i don't
understand this this seems completely
wrong
i think this is
the parameter alpha there is a parameter
alpha you are forgetting that it control
you know it's not a unique you know it's
not a unique object
this thing right here is of
infinitesimal thickness correct
if i look inside here there is not a
thickened wall
there these if i were to poke through
that face i would be in the interior
right can i can i explain something
okay so this example right normally you
should have to put a parameter alpha
which define
the ball you are going to use
i know that so depending on your sample
the way you sample the point
no no it's getting a definite output
there's there's a definite answer here
either when i poke through that face i
get to the interior or i don't or i get
to some thickened 3d object
what i want to explain is that why we
pick the input to be a mesh region the
input can also be a boundary mesh region
i'm trying to explain why
we decide that by default we return a
mesh region instead of the full
dimension boundary mesh region where in
some cases it should be possible
right the function right so if you give
him a ball like in this case you sample
the ball dance enough we can return you
a boundary mesh region
right so the point of in the design
right now is do we want to in some cases
return a boundary mesh region or a mesh
region
the idea was that since everybody
is a standard people are doing surface
reconstruction so we return you the
surface
because surface causes compression tend
to think about a surface then the 2d
case should be curve reconstruction
and not you know for that annulus it
should be the curve in that case that's
the analog that's path we can go that
way that's because you can't be
inconsistent between the two because
that's you know
right so so let's let's go through the
two cases right
so case number one is we are
reconstructing merely the surface merely
the boundary
right actually just just ask a quick
quick question i mean if you made alpha
a billion would that still just be the
boundary
or would it maybe have some interior
cells so for this construction of alpha
said when alpha gets large you get a
convex hole
yeah right but you still so that means
the full dimension
why
why
no it's not no no no no either we always
do this dessert because or not it
doesn't matter what the alpha is well
that's why we pick mesh region is what
i'm trying to explain that's why we
decided to return you a mesh region and
we stick with it
right
but if alpha is a billion and it returns
the convex hull is the convex is it the
surface of the convex hull or is it a
convex hollows a as a full
filled cell
it's just better so how do i get that i
would say boundary mesh of is that
correct so in in your example they put
you know 10 20
right of the ball i don't understand
this i don't understand what just
happened here why did i not get the pure
region boundaries
okay
so
again why didn't this if if i were using
the correct convex hull concave hull
mesh whatever we call it
i would expect that the analogy to
getting this
would be to get this
exactly
exactly okay and and i agree with you
and is in our universe of consistency
right we like to have system think
consistency output consistent but when
people actually use it
right in dimension two like somebody
will sample you know let's take a font
you know glyph s you sample it and then
you say
you know
give me the shape like you're not
selling me on this yeah i understand
what you're saying that that's
look if you want the interior you need a
different function that gives you the
interior as well
one of these is giving you the surface
and one of the you is giving the best
reconstruction of the interior including
holes
so maybe there should just be some
reconstruct you know boundary mesh and
reconstruct mesh or maybe those are the
wrong names should be consistent i mean
so it could just be two functions to do
these just in case yes yeah or at least
being able to specify the goals but but
let's you know
what what you're probably
missing here what i'm trying to say is
that a mesh region can represent a
boundary mesh region always yes of
course there is no
cool interior structure so there is no
inconce and consistency that that
exactly no no no no no
what you said was still inconsistent
the fact that in 2d yes
what what i meant is the following that
ball example there right we are just
right now disregarding the point we can
decide to actually return you to fully
tried on inside exactly but yes so we
have to decide which to do
exactly we can't do a different thing in
2d and then 3d i perfectly agree i'm
just that was
exactly what i was saying that is a
matter of goal of what you want to use
at the end right now we just decided for
the time being to just return the
surface we can actually run the
construction to return you the full
object
okay all right okay so that means we've
got two functions we're dealing with
here okay they are both filtered the
lawn eye meshes am i correct
they're both you start from the delaney
mesh and then you delete things correct
all right
so
the
okay so maybe just to know i mean in
this cert in the case where you're only
keeping the surface right there the
boundary you're destroying most of the
delano mesh right all the triangles are
i mean not all the time but most of them
are going to go away right right
so the fact that it started you know the
fact it comes from a dilemma mesh at
that point is probably pretty irrelevant
right so the case where it was a full
dolani mesh with just some with holes of
above some size removed right that's
that's one case is you've got it a
longer mesh you remove holes above some
size
below yeah above some size
correct
is that correct
yes
okay so one function that we have
is some kind of
i wouldn't call it a holy delano mesh
but a um
it's something which is based on delano
mesh but with holes removed
um that's case number one case number
two
is we're attempting to
i mean
number two is just region boundary of
that
right
that is correct
but but
which is also related to surface plot 3d
so i mean we
yes it's exactly that isn't it
it's you remember
so
you know the the the
let's take the annulus on your left
there
just scroll up but that's a tad
let's say that we did a reconstruction
and remove the holes you then take the
boundary of that
you get two circles
which is not the same as two
sorry which is not that which is not
like the convex hull where you get a
region that is the
whatever this kind of region is this
whatever it is this one here right
where there's where there's region where
there's interior in it so
this is a whole lot i mean this there's
a more fundamental question which is
what is the input right so the input
could either be
you know these are points sampled from
the interior of the region or it could
be these are points sampled from the
boundary right
okay so if you if you really allow me to
explain okay
so here essentially we are following a
standard method of reconstructions right
which in some case you can it will carry
those lower dimension or not that's
right so for example
let's take the 3d case there you have a
ball
right what normally we should return is
that boundary mesh which contain the
interior
right and if you run that same code but
with a sphere will return you the
surface
it's just crazy i mean it just no no no
no it's not crazy is it messed up does
that make sense
it makes sense it's the object
right so we pick
to return you then you know instead of
moving between a boundary mesh and mesh
with john we decided to return you at
least for now a measure and in this case
of the ball
normally when we finish your
implementation we are going to give you
actually the point
inside so if somebody do a sphere you
have this fear because i was just going
to tell you that okay but you're on that
okay fine yeah so it's what i mean that
we are you know is that direction we are
going and we are preserving those
points yeah that makes sense
okay roger reads announcing this to me
oh somebody re-explained yeah yeah so
here the two cases let's take ball and
here so a ball has a filled interior a
sphere is just a shell right
let's say that you're given points from
a ball you have a bunch of interior
points
it makes sense when we reconstruct that
we also have the interior yes you know
tetrahedra this one doesn't currently
return it but that's intention is that
it would
if you have points from a sphere
you only really want the the surface
right
and so in in which case
uh that's what you want you know they
should have dimension two like the thing
that's okay hold on hold on hold on
let's say i've got some experimental
data and it really came from a sphere
but there's some noise in the data
yeah is it i think it's not a sphere
right
okay this is this is where the alpha
comes in i think
but yes but we can't change the return
type depending on that value
well we're gonna well we're gonna have
to switch anyways at some point right
why
none of it that's why we wanted to no no
no no i take it back
exactly i was going to say stephen we
we're not changing the return type
we're never returning a boundary mesh
we're always returning a mesh
even the mesh presentation is not
efficient right but we turn you to full
mesh yeah okay so
to see what i'm saying the type is the
very same all right okay okay okay all
right so given all of this
what you're saying is
this is essentially
a
what would happen if we called this
something like
you know
course and mesh or ball course and mesh
i don't think it helps people
do you do well
i mean first of all
i don't want to know what it is no no i
i i
i want to sort of put some more work
into the description of what it does
and
well i think we know what it does
basically at this point we it is making
the world
but but people can't call us
you know and they would get confused if
they did so we we need to write it down
i i know that roger but i'm trying to
get
what is the qualitative description of
what's going on you are making icing i
see you're you're making a mesh
and
at the lorna mesh as it turns out
but we may not want to tell people it's
italian i mesh in the name right you're
making it the lawn eye mesh and then you
are
is it coarsely or what is it it's it's a
it's it's a um
what is the right word for for something
where a thing that is a hole
is being dropped out
what would you call that a porous
delaney mesh
that's not right either because porous
suggests that there are pores in it
holes in it if you understand what i
mean which they're they're not holes of
that kind it is
so essentially what it's doing is
fitting cells
of a certain measure
it's what it's removing cells below a
certain measure or above a certain
measure no below us what's it
yes roughly yeah below so kind of that
fitting but that's not what's happening
here
it's not doing that it's it's a
it's leaving the edges that are above a
certain measure
so actually i mean
i mean maybe this is this is off topic
but like i mean if you have for example
3d scanned you know point cloud data
right where all the points are from the
surface of the things you're looking at
i mean that's a case where i think you
would actually like to get a boundary
mesh out
i mean maybe there there could be a
different function for that
but
um i don't know it just seems like that
that case is probably fairly common and
worth supporting
but you have look around you but you
have no god yes but you have you know
that's why we kind of stick with the
surface but because you have no
guarantee that your construction will be
actually closed volume
same case like let's let's this surface
plot 3d but we have function or we
should actually add the function we take
a mesh
and then generate the boundary mesh the
volume
the problem is just that the problem is
that it might not be a well a
well-formed boundary
exactly like you might have a giant hole
in it yeah okay i see yeah yes
we've done some of this we want to come
back from where the rabbit the stand of
the rabbit
is that right which you can't scan
yeah for instance
so we we
repair mesh does some of that okay
for 3d printing but when you take
i think there are more methods that one
can use basically
but i guess i guess kind of the point
being though that
so
that might mean though that we want to
have a separate function maybe in the
future that returns a boundary mesh and
that really is a surface reconstruction
thing in which case this function could
maybe be
a more pure
interior reconstruction no let's let's
not mix but because the thought was that
we'll have a
construct mesh which will have the
different goal and then the goal will be
give me the surface or give me the
full dimension object right
or the closed object or the
object we satisfy the following criteria
and then we do the magic to generate
through the reconstructed object right
where
there's a candidate page if you want to
bring it up right where in this scale of
this uh convex whole mesh is a specific
technique where there is you know we
return you what i mean that you have
that construction and then we just
return you the resulting object from it
right so there's you know sure
right this is a valuable construction
just like delany is a valuable
construction
the alpha shape of course right but if
we're talking about the reconstruction
thing i mean i guess i'm just like
it just seems like
it seems like there are two different
cases here one of them is you have a set
of points on the boundary one of them
you have a set of points on the interior
and and it kind of i mean maybe i'm
misunderstood in standing which case you
know just ignore me but like
it sort of sounds like this function
that we're trying to name right now
is sort of like in the 2d case it's kind
of assuming that the points are on the
interior and on the 3d case it's sort of
it's like it's sort of trying to handle
both cases
and and i'm not sure that makes sense
um no so if you if well
so the the the key idea is the following
right is
well because we tend to use the mesh
right but it's essentially if you have a
set of points right and you you
construct the neighbors right you are
going to get a cell right in 2d you will
get triangles in 3d you may get you know
triangle like for a sphere
or when you have a ball you can actually
get it hydrant because you have you know
closest point
right and so based on those cells
you pick those ones will fit nicely
above
and that's what help you to construct
pretty much your original surface so if
you have a you know a 3d object which
have interior point you'll be able to
reconstruct those interior point
if the object is just purely
surface so you just have triangle on the
surface
then you don't have that you know that
volume inside
okay so they're just out of you know
curiosity you know for for
imagining that this worked in n
dimensions just so we can see if it's
consistent right so basically you're
constructing the n-dimensional delano
mesh which consists of a bunch of you
know n simplices right or something like
that right
and then what you're doing is you're
you're you're selecting the edges that
are that are length less than alpha
and then
and then you're deleting all of the
cells with dimension less than less than
or equal to one is that right so you'll
have i don't think you have surfaces and
you'll have 3d simplices and you'll have
40 simplicities and so on
so this this function
extend to a quite a polytop in nd
definitely right but that technique of
reconstruction of the dolany is easily
visible
or most of the cases in 2d really
i mean the thing i'm just asking though
is just that
because it seems like because my
impression is that in in 2d it is
deleting if there's some lone edge
poking out into space you know after
you've after you've pruned out the edges
that are longer than alpha if there's
one edge that doesn't get pruned out but
it's not it doesn't have any associated
triangle that that edge gets deleted but
then in 3d if you have a triangle that's
sort of on its own
you know that's not part of a simplex it
does not get deleted so i guess my
question is is the rule just that things
with dimension one or less get deleted
regardless of what the embedding
dimension is
or is the rule
or is there all kind of inconsistent
between the you know
the embedding dimensions
okay
look
exactly i mean we i thought we we
clarified that before but
i i'm so irreducibly confused now and
several people in our livestream adding
their suggestions and
okay let's go through again
what
okay first of all does it make sense in
the future to have reconstructed mesh
reconstructed boundary mesh does that
make sense
i think that if you look in that page we
have a more general proposal than that
the page called reconstruction mesh is
that correct yes
and this is an early draft but
you can see
sort of
it's called cons here i would say
goals but
well that's an interesting way to do it
so that will be a list of things that
you want like an orientable
something or other
you'd give a bunch of constraints that
you're trying to seek
right but then the returned object
would be a boundary mesh or it would be
the interior mesh
i think that that's another part of a
goal that needs to be
specified so for instance
it's actually useful in reconstruction
to say that you're seeking let's say a
hypersurface
you know so a surface in 3d or a curve
in
2d um
i think that's a useful constraint
actually
sure
because it allows you that
the question you just asked me that the
data is noisy
is it uh yeah do you want the thickened
thing
with its interior or do you just want
the best 2d surface
right
right so it's almost like there's simply
a a thing which is the dimension of the
object that you want to get out
is it the full you know literally you're
saying two or three
in the case of the teapot
you might want
you know the best fit of the surface or
the interior or
okay so
i think so you're basically saying the
target dimension well okay i guess
they're technically two different things
there's i want a boundary mesh which
represents a 3d object with a 2d
boundary or it could be you're saying
the object that i'm giving you points
now the object you're trying to
reconstruct i you know is of dimension
two even though it's embedded in
dimension three and i want you to return
a surface which is a mesh region
i would suspect we want
reconstruction mesh and reconstruction
boundary mesh as two separate functions
where the reconstruction boundary mesh
returns a boundary mesh object and
reconstruction mesh returns a mesh
object well my claim is that we don't
really need it
because we can always represent a
boundary mesh as a mesh region
right like we did for you know
discretization is because there you want
an output with that form but where in
this case it's what we cannot have both
functions i mean there's no big
difference it's just one line of code to
mix both
this is
clear it's not useful because you can
always run boundary mesh and get the
boundary mesh
no
right you can always we have utility
functions i think it's useful for the
concept of the thing
okay but
i'm not sure but this this function
seems pretty
reasonable um
okay now it's a little raw it's too raw
no but i i understand that i understand
that so the question is what is this
function which is supposed to be now
which one of those is it going to be
it could be either of them couldn't it
could be either the one that is giving
dimension two here or the one that's
giving dimension three here am i correct
yeah
okay so we gotta figure out how we deal
with that maybe it's two different
functions or maybe it's an argument to
the function but it can't just be we
choose whichever one we feel like
okay so the question is
are we is the name something that is
based on the word the lawn eye mesh
i really don't like this ball idea i
think that's totally confusing because i
think it makes it suggest that the thing
will be a composite of a bunch of balls
which will be a perfectly reasonable way
to represent a region in space but
that's not this
am i making sense
it's not this
right so we don't want the word ball in
there i don't think
um
so the question is do we want the lorna
mesh in the name or not
question what do you think
well i don't think we should have the
lanai mesh the lanai in the name is more
a technique to construct it i mean
okay
i mean another way of thinking about it
delanoy i mean the lawn my meshes relate
to so many of these different different
constructions i mean even things like
voronoi meshes and stuff like that where
it's the dual i mean
there are lots of things you would call
a delano mesh anytime it was this
closely related
yeah the other question
jos i mean conceptually one can view it
as a filter dylani but but when i think
one can construct it directly right and
then
okay fine so the dollar is not in the
name
okay so what is the description of this
thing
it is a thing where there's a minimum
cell size right
is that the right way to think about it
yes
is it cell sizes
that's why i'm preferring these things
like course and mesh and things
it's it's not a coarsening though
that kind of assumes that costing that
means you already have something right
work here pc you don't so we kind of
build those cells and then do the course
thing
all the filtering after that
what's the possibility of having this be
the early version of reconstruction mesh
with the with this being the default
method
and then adding constraints later for
reconstruction mesh
i mean reconstruct i really think we
should have this as a standalone concept
i i it's it's
all right in computational geometry it's
it's
almost as fundamental as
as dylan all right okay okay well fine
but then then it needs a name and there
need to be two versions of it right one
that gives the boundary and one that
gives the interior
correct so if the point if if we're
having it as its own function because
it's sort of a known concept in
computational geometry
at some level then then it should be
named what it's called in computational
geometry but i think we decided that
name is too crazy it is concave for mesh
oh god
no or alpha shapes oh alpha shape oh
come on
i mean i feel like method arrow alpha
shapes or something would be okay
yeah but it just feels a little bit it's
just a crazy thing it's just a crazy
thing it's some
it's probably a brand name for some type
of 3d scanner or something at some point
i i don't know who knows what it was but
it's a not an interesting name and also
the alpha parameters the wrong way up
you know one thing that just struck me
is the guy that came up with alpha
shapes is this guy edelsberner was a
professor at u of i
yes
yeah and then he did a spin-off company
that did
uh reconstruction
indeed
fancy that probably using alpha shapes
well i mean uh i'm thinking you know i
mean that wasn't what
because it was you know it was doing out
it was constructing nurbs and cat models
and stuff in the end but
well so maybe it should be called what
was his name
i don't know
good point
going eponymous all the way
well it's what we would do for special
functions
right well why not
because nobody will know what it is
and because it probably had multiple
origins and we have to research that
i mean not that
i you know
not that delaney was the first with
delony no doubt
but but we're using sort of conventional
names and and that one isn't one
okay what are we going to call this
thing
i mean concave whole mesh is just a
stupid
plus it's not even describing how would
we deal with the surface versus interior
question
what would be your let's imagine that we
set use concave whole mesh which i'm not
think which i don't think is a good idea
but if we did that how do we deal with
the surface versus interior
yeah charles
you mean in the term of the name or in
some of the outputs
no
neither neither we need both cases right
we need both it produces the interior
and it produces the surface
right we need both of those not switched
automatically
that's not what we're going to do
that's what we're going to do for
reconstruction mesh with its second
argument but not for this this is
supposed to be a building block function
that does not auto magically decide what
dimension its output is
i mean i normally fall
doesn't change the dimension we are not
changing we have we are following a
process a standard construction same has
a special form no it's not right it's
not right in this case does it have an
interior or not
right
you that that is something you can't
choose differently whether this has an
interior or this has an interior
no
it's either that both surfaces or
they're both with the interior
am i missing something here
roger can you no no i agree i agree okay
so we've got two different things does
it have the interior or does it not have
the interior
correct am i am i missing a mix missing
anything yeah
so i mean maybe it could just have an
argument you know it has the mesh it has
the radius and then has a third argument
which which i think you know which are
basically the dimension
what would you say basically the the
minimum dimension of any cell that it
keeps right so all the cells with lower
dimension it deletes which is my i think
is how you would get the
the boundary as opposed to getting the
interior
right so if you wanted the boundary in
this annulus case you'd say you know
whatever mesh of your points comma
automatic comma
uh and then you'd say one
and it would give you just the the curve
and if you said two then it would give
you the the actual annulus
so which is that okay
so
if you allow me to say it again and
you know maybe we are going to look
again the same discussion right
so
this is a specific method construction
i don't care we
i don't care i don't care that people
have conventionally done this or that
nobody is going to understand it the
fact that we've spent an hour and a half
talking about it is a very very bad sign
in terms of anybody else's ability to
understand it i was about to talk about
the resulting output not the name
okay
the resulting output somebody can come
and say the result of the following
function whatever we call it it's wrong
i will you know
it'll be easy and clear to justify it
and so essentially the construction
at least the standard construction is
from the dolomite triangular position
where you cover
the cells and then you take the cells
inside the bowl there is no ambiguity
there
the cells you are picking are precise so
that means we know exactly
the
n-dimension object you are generating
is not related to the representation we
have in the word form language that we
return a boundary mesh or a mesh region
is a specific r and object
right that that makes
sense right but i think that the
case where it's breaking down is just
that after you do the important step of
selecting the edges you know the edges
that are
not not the not the simplicities but the
edges that are you know
christopher you are thinking about edges
in dimension two and then you jump in
dimension n
that's not the same
oh so so in dimension n d are you not
selecting are you are you selecting you
know triangles you look at the d minus
one face the d minus one cell because in
the
way when you look at you look at the you
know polytops right you describe them
with the d minus one cells in dimension
two you describe it with the you know d
minus one which is the edges in your
case
okay so there's that structure
this is the thing i didn't understand
this entire time okay so so in in 3d
it's not selecting edges or it's not
deleting edges it's deleting triangles
is that right
exactly that cells that's why the sphere
you can have that object that's you know
that surface to that construction
okay thank you that that was the thing i
did not understand the entire time okay
now it now it actually makes sense
can you explain this to me
okay the point just being that it's it's
and that's also why that picture you had
in the uh
in the in the in the documentation
that's actually probably the the nicer
picture to show okay so basically it's
just that
it's
instead of filtering you know instead of
just filtering the edges it's filtering
the the simplest c's and you know the d
minus one dimension cells
right i mean like charles just said
so in in 3d you're deleting triangles
right so you're going to end up with
some set of you know and
so right in 2d you're deleting edges
and in 3d you're deleting triangles and
so if you delete a bunch of triangles
you're going to end up you could end up
with just a surface
or you might end up with some
cells where you know some tetrahedrons
where all four of their triangles have
what happens to a tetrahedron which has
one face removed what do you do with the
tetrahedron it's a tetrahedron with a
face missing it's got a hole in it
but then it isn't a tetrahedron well
right so
then it's just the surfaces of the
tetrahedron
yes
so i mean the water is allowed
in that case
right so i guess
right i mean in terms of how it's
actually represented i mean so i guess
the point is if a tetrahedron keeps all
of its faces does it remain a solid
tetrahedron but then if it loses one it
all of a sudden becomes a shell
or yeah what does happen in that case
that's why we decided to return it as a
mesh region right then in that case you
are losing you know okay so as a mesh
region it goes from a three-dimensional
mesh three-dimensional cell that is the
tetrahedron to
let's say it has one face removed to
three
two dimensional
cells
that are just faces is that correct
yes so mesh region can represent all
those things i know it can represent all
those things it can represent cells of
different dimensions
if the you know i think that's probably
okay right because just if you have high
enough resolution points
then then it doesn't matter but but
there will be a value
to filtering the output so that it is
only a thing of a given dimension
because if you think you want a surface
you don't want random extra little
tetrahedra in your surface as little you
know hard bits so to speak
are we making sense if you want
something surface you want a surface you
do not want tetrahedra embedded in your
surface but i think that when there's
not this construction
well or we have we should have utility
to filter right we have
and somewhere in that surface
there are little embedded tetrahedra
because your data was a little bit too
fuzzy in that region right yeah it's a
gaussian noise thing and your alpha
value was such that blah blah blah
absolutely okay so now what do you do
with that
so
so that's why we'll have several
reconstruction functions no no no no no
no no no that's not an answer in this
particular case i want to know what do
we do with that how do we turn that into
the pure surface
this one i think in this case it doesn't
handle the noises it's what i want to
say this is a specific method that is
this is like
it's a specific construction i know that
i know that so i'm asking the question
how would you go from the thing
reconstructed by this
that has a surface with random
tetrahedral bits in it what do you do
next i think it's just you don't right i
mean it's just that's a different
function
this function leaves you the tetrahedral
bits and you know if you're doing
computational geometry you want them
anyway
okay right if you're studying alpha
shapes you want the tetrahedral bits
all right so
this is
a mesh where you are keeping
everything
it is some kind of
thresholded mesh
is that a fair way to say it
where you don't keep a cell
that is below a certain size
right is that the correct thing to say
and where the cells are in d minus one
dimensions where d is the embedded
dimension
right
is that right i mean
what's the right term if if this was
image processing
what would you be doing it's a blurred
mesh of some kind
what's the concept
right what are other cases where you are
removing
things below a certain feature size
pruned
i mean what about something like
i mean it's more like it's removing
things that are too far apart
you know they're not
right right that is right i mean it's
removing things
okay so it is
this is hopeless i mean that this is
okay
the name
reconstructed mesh for example that's a
perfectly good name i think
and that's that needs
additional work but i agree with you
so maybe we have to go with concave hull
yuck
yuck
is that name much more popular than
alpha shapes
i haven't tested it well it's
it's the one people use for
reconstructions yes it's more convenient
oh so you call them alpha shapes if
you're doing something other than
reconstructions basically
well you call it after shape when you
when you want to construct you know you
want to describe that family of objects
you are getting right so
the object it produces is an alpha shape
exactly so it's you know it's a
algorithm
okay but but the process is
this convex hull mesh concave concave
yeah yeah
so the other thing that gradient mesh
that you like that name
i mean it's at least nice in that it
tells you what it takes as its argument
oh gradient fit mesh
no i think gradient well what the only
problem with gradient mesh is it might
you might think it's something like
boundary mesh
why is it why would it be gradient fit
mesh
because we are actually seating the
gradient
right where gradient
mesh may think that like you say you
know or kind of a tangent
you know a differential geometry type of
mesh you get from
by computing you know the tangents what
do you mean by you fitting the mesh
you're you are making it you are given a
bunch of gradients is that correct
yes yeah
and then you compute that fit that mesh
while you have the best fit
i think gradient mesh is okay
could it be called tangent mesh
because the mesh is also tangent to all
of the vectors you're giving it right
but we tend to use gradient right to
explicit
value than tangent
it's tangent to the orthogonal
complement to it
i mean it's
by the way for a comment for various
people on live stream like sander
convex hull we have the issue is what to
do with this thing that isn't the convex
hull
that is
that is
selecting other that is selecting out
things that are
non-convex part i mean that what it's
been called in the go ahead
no sorry i'm just right it's basically
just reconstruction but the problem is
that the non-convex cell mesh is not you
know might actually be convex
so isn't that lovely so can a concave
thing actually be convex no
unless okay then why is it called
concave hull mesh if it can actually be
convex
okay it's like saying if if something is
non-decreasing can it also be
non-increasing yes it can
if it's zero
it's like how non-linear bottle fit can
return you a linear model
yes it's like
can something be convex and concave yes
if it's linear
okay so
you're arguing okay the question is
okay
okay so
the possibilities here seem to so the
first point is reconstructed mesh or
reconstruction mesh not completely clear
which one is right
is
a project for the future
hopefully soon very soon yes
but
okay
but so the question now is we are
basically making something that's going
to have a ridiculously technical name
by the way if we were going to create
gradient fitted mesh wouldn't that be
the right term not gradient fit mesh
gradient fitted mesh
is that the right i guess i guess so
yeah
i think that's actually a better name
than gradient mesh it removes one
confusion
isn't that too close with defeated mesh
what is fitted mesh
fitted region something we made last
time
oh sorry yeah that's fine which does
what
it fits parametric regions
disk
you know
like line right right right right right
but this fits a mesh to gradients
correct
yes yes
well so should it be gradient mesh and
we don't try to explain the fitting
thing or should it be gradient fitted
mesh
i kind of tend to agree with
a gradient fitted sounds it's a little
longer but it says what it does and it
will be similar to the fitted region and
the constructed mesh and
what is it is it correctly similar to
that
are you are you supporting this name
charles
okay all right let's go with that
and the first order necessary conditions
are
is the poisson equation
that's why it's what's called pause on
mesh before
um where am i keeping all this stuff
drama tray
uh you could you could save it there
that's fine i think last time you
emailed it but
this stuff
okay so we we've got now
so i think reconstructed region and a
sorry reconstructed mesh and and
probably for the future approximated
either either reconstruction mesh and
approximation mesh
or approximate that presumably if it's
going to follow the same yeah right it's
either approximation or approxim
approximated
reconstructed mesh and approximated mesh
seems
like the better thing to me
okay so now the question is what to call
this creature right now
and
i think we have the names no i mean
the concave hull thing
yeah
all right an hour and a half later we
come back to where it started from
all right i don't i don't see an
alternative because i don't think
there's anything else any any other name
we come up with we have to develop a
whole story behind and we're going to do
that for reconstructed mesh and
approximated mesh
but we won't do it for the more
technical thing
right
all right fine maybe there should be a
note in the details it says that it
concave mesh may not may return a convex
hull or maybe return a convex mesh or
something
yes it should definitely say
um
okay one last time any other thoughts
about what this could be
i mean i feel like if the point is that
this is a thing that people who know
computational geometry will be using and
other people will be using
reconstructing reconstructed whatever
mesh
then it has to be either called concave
hall or alpha shapes
and alpha shapes is crazy could it get
away with non-convex hull
no
that has the same problem anyway yeah i
know it does
no i agree with you christopher that's
how i okay kate as well
yes
yeah right
all right
concave hall mesh i guess it is
splurf
all right let's get to reconstructed
mesh and approximated mesh as soon as we
can
like next version right
that realistic
roger
i think so okay fine
let's just look very quickly at these
other things if we can get through at
least the geometry part of this and then
we've got another oops
region convert right
so
what is this for really is this is this
this is an incredibly useful utility
function for people that program to do
programming with geometry
it allows you to convert between
different representations we've had this
hidden underneath this
multi-representation
people keep asking for it all the time
so this is the kind of thing you want to
use a lot when you start programming
geometry
it is very interesting that we've never
had to have a thing like this for graphs
but that's been a successful place where
we can hide the internal representation
well no i mean we have a bunch of things
for graph you can get matrices you can
get incidence matrices adjacency
matrices fair enough fair enough all
kinds of things
but but but geometry is sort of an order
of magnitude more complex in the sense
that there is no
one finite representation
and
not only that
the
the um the downstream clients for
compute
they
require different kinds of things
depending on you know which theory it is
so for instance
if you're going to integrate over a
region
there is no implicit definition
you have to have a parametric
representation in differential geometry
they use the implicit function theorem
to get a locally parametric
representation
it requires a parametric representation
if you do optimization
it's all done with implicit
representation that's how constraints
are done in optimization
and so you you'll find this repeatedly
in all kinds of places that
that the the compute side
you know a domain or a community is
honed in and a particular kind of
representation and you need to be able
to okay between them okay okay fine
let's go through a few of these why you
say solid taurus then you immediately
describe it as filled taurus
yeah we have solid anything
do we use the name solid for anything
uh
we probably don't actually
so did we already have taurus or no
no
oh okay
well so we've got ball versus sphere
disk versus a circle
what's an annulus is an annulus annulus
is the is the interior region
annulus is field yeah
i do this is sort of like a 2d taurus in
a way
kind of 2d filled taurus
yes
yes
i mean the analog kit will be some kind
of ring type thing but that's a really
stupid idea
yes
i think filled taurus is better than
solid taurus especially since presumably
it can be a tourist in any of dimensions
no
why not
and in principle we don't have to
support it today but in principle this
could be an end taurus could it not
which involves a product of n circles
am i confused
maybe you're right
you can you run uh filled question mark
filled star
refill star or something
we have filled curve
a filled curve is very much like this
same concept for a filled taurus is it
not
yes
you know the spacings could could
whoever's pm here just make a note of
this this just really goofed up
the way that spacing works
why is this sparked down
right the spacing is wrong the font size
is wrong come on we can do better
um
filled taurus seems better to me
to go along with filled curve
okay so these things there is no visible
change other than that we can compute
volumes of these things and lengths of
them and so on right
yeah and you use them in a whole
uh
compute framework the whole company you
know compute geometry i know it's very
impressive i mean i'm sure has no
documentation impact but a very
impressive piece of implementation
yeah i mean as a matter of fact we do if
you go and look at their
primitives they have sort of two sides
to the documentation examples there's
the compute side and there's the
rendering side i was just looking but
yeah right i don't think it's in there
yet
no not yet
not for these new ones
and and
and it needs sort of a refresh like we
did for all the other ones when we
introduced geometry okay
let's just have a quick look at
geometric
wait a minute geometric transformation
what's the difference between that and
and the
so those first group there we're only
applicable to in graphics graphics and
graphics 3d
and we now accept them in geometry so
they can be used
you know so you can take a sphere for
example and i could say
if i say
something like
you're telling me that what i could do
here is say something like this
and well you're saying if i do this arc
length for instance
arclang for that for instance
how would i compute this just
numerically
uh you you integrate
um no no i know what i know what
the calculation is i'm asking you here
if i wanted this to be just a numerical
computation rather than the symbolic
thing it's trying and failing to do
a working position
right oh nobody will ever know that
what can you just say n
of the shearing
transform
um
would it automatically go to numeric
methods if it's approximate if it's
finite position it should and actually
here we showed each i think it's you
know we are still working on the you
know refining it but it should you know
figure out if you can do the integration
fast enough
that's fine so that's lovely but but now
so and why is that so slow
you know it's just that i should just
wow
well let's go you and i can
yeah
i'm
surprised okay
okay what is region transform
okay that's a totally different thing
that's gonna be such a have a such a
similar name would be totally different
it finds a transform okay so if you use
translation transform
rotation transform all of those things
produce transforms right
so why isn't it called find region
transformation i think it should be
probably actually that's the name we
haven't updated that was the final name
we proposed well actually why is it not
hold on doesn't find geometric transform
or find geometric transportation
whatever it's called doesn't it already
take graphics primitives or something
like that
no um no but that's a good point
actually where we discuss about you know
we have been you know
look at this so find geometry transform
it
it's actually those more refitting
problems than actually finding the
transformation
so region trans find region transform
give you the actual transformation or at
least one of them
right between two regions where this one
does the fitting
and if you also look at the function the
output is actually roughly actually the
output is the inverse transform right
because you give the mapping from
p2 to p1
it's because
the convention is backwards for images
you recall yep
this is kind of highly this is obviously
another discussion
we need to schedule yet another
yeah and that is basically to find so
the two things congruent is when there
is a rigid transform
between two regions
and a similar tr you know two regions
are similar when there is a
rigid plus scaling
right but but these things here these
are tests and that's fine right the
region transform or find region
transform is the one that actually finds
that if you want the mapping
right
so i mean it should
okay but we've got to understand the
relationship for find geometric
transform sure
by the way one other reason why it
should be find region transform or
something like that and not region
transform is that don't we already have
like transformed region
and yes we do
okay i would always accidentally use
region transform instead of transformed
region if both of them existed
right this thing is output transform the
other one as output region
right right right so so transformed
region does what and how does it relate
to all of these
you take a region
and you transform it with some affine or
non you know linear non-linear okay and
then the result of that would be a new
region yeah you know
whether it can whether it can represent
it in closed form or not it is a new
region as it is i'm saying that
representation is a region
so sometimes it comes back unevaluated
exactly most of the time
you know
it's not it's not that it's coming back
and evaluated transform region represent
the wage it's just that
yeah
which is different right so the
transformed region could often be region
congruent by the way does region
congruent return conditions is that why
it's not a q function
yes
so it'll give you you can't have q
functions for things with parameters
they they no i understand that i
understand that so this becomes like a
reduced type thing
right this this can say if if the angle
alpha is 90 degrees then it will be
congruent otherwise it won't be correct
yes yes yes
which is nice
and how does it relate to the congruent
stuff that's in the
um
geometric assertion business and so on
well i should congruent should always
mean the same thing
no roger roger i don't care i'm asking
you there's a whole big system that's
been built for synthetic geometry how
does what you have built here relate to
that
do you understand the question
right so like geometric assertion and so
on have you talked to those
that sounds like an assertion
that one is an assertion but there's a
there's a related test
right what's the related test
geometric test
okay try to give it a few regions and
see if it can compute anything no it
can't do anything with region right
but it has the concept of congruent and
so on right
right and yeah
the objects are congruent
i haven't checked but in principle they
should coincide the output so i will
make sure we you know make sure it does
and make sure that both things get to
use each other
are making sense yes
okay
we still need to talk about these
transform things
um
and
i just want to look ahead at these
because this looks like a lovely idea
let me just see that
and then we have to wrap and go to our
next
meeting which is also a live stream
about video
so where's the example do we have
examples yet for this
not yet
but so the way this will work it will
say lighting arrow and then a symbolic
list of spotlights and things is that
correct
yes
that's lovely then you can also have
them in line in the scene
so in other words you can you can
differently light different parts of the
scene yes but didn't we didn't we add
that capability
several versions ago
yeah so you can have lighting goes to a
list of things in outline which is
very strange
very very very strange yes
that's very crazy strange
and this one is more kind of additive
right so you can actually make a nested
sequence
i see so so you can have
go ahead go ahead
go ahead
oh all right i mean i'm just
so you can have it in style as well
presumably
yes yes
but now what happens if you want
three-point lighting for this part of
the scene and you want something else
for another part of the scene how do you
do that with these prone tips
one object with one set of lights and
another object lit with it
we got banks switched lighting
descriptions for the lighting option i'm
asking how do you bring those in to the
style for an individual object in the
scene
well so you can
so the three point light is actually
directional light so you can do you know
directional light tripoint light
right and if you want to have it in
different scene you can control the
scope by you know
but it doesn't necessarily there's no
guarantee that one of these banks
switched lighting settings is just one
type of this
do you see what i'm saying
right there's no guarantee of that yes
there's no county right so
what we should have
is some kind of primitive
that might have been called lighting
except that that
isn't the right um
i mean it's like it's it's like color
data
right it's something like color data
where this isn't quite the same thing
either but some primitive that is an
inline primitive that can be put into
style
oh actually no no what am i saying what
am i saying there's an obvious way to do
this right all you have to do
is to allow style
to take lighting and then you're done
like this
right then that's how you put it in
see what i'm saying
that's a possibility
that seems the right thing
um
okay there's a few comments on our
livestream that we need to wrap up and
uh
uh ali is asking for the voronoi mesh in
3d which is coming right guys
it's going to be there in this version
right guys
yes
yippee
long awaited varnamesh 3d
it's that's that's one of those um
you know cheer moments
um
okay geometric scene 3d muhammad is
asking for yeah well
uh
that's hard
um
oh sandra is saying that style sphere
lighting arrow or whatever already works
yes
well so what are we talking about so
that then then there's no problem with
this
then we don't need an inline primitive
there
so it was saying graphics 3d
of this i don't know what the lighting
specification what give me give me two
liking specifications please
welcome
accent
and another one please tell
what do you know just worked
great
lovely
and so then the alternative to this
would be to be able to say something
like
in here
uh just spotlight
is that right i would say it here or
where would i say it
either there or
or as a inline before you know like
color
right
what's its argument
is it a position position
not happy
what's it saying here
an improperly formatted directive with
head spotlight was encountered
so something is wrong
i assume it does it is supported in
style right it needs to be
right
yeah we'll check that
i think is it work if you say lighting
arrow
spotlight
let's just try this
this is the inline version
so it's probably taking the color sorry
spotlight take a first color and then
the position
oops
well okay
not yet working
uh okay one last thing here from doug
find geometric transform from points one
to points two is already function okay
fine region transform seems appropriate
okay if there's one canonical
transformation between regions i mean
clearly clearly if i mean one of the
issues which i no doubt we'll talk about
next time is if you have the you know
the cut out of the elephant
and it is more or less rigidly rotated
but actually you distorted the piece of
paper slightly what does it do
you will fail
you will find with exact transform so
well but what if it's numerical data
what if it what if the elephant is is
outlined with you know approximate
numbers
well we'll work with approximate number
but we don't have to handle noise or
anything like that so there must be a
tolerance of some kind
but i mean by default we use the the the
system tolerance which is 10 to minus 12
from the numerical level
okay but we can add okay so it's only
rigid so you're saying it is only rigid
transformations that work
yes and similar and similar
similar transformations we we need to
talk about it some more because clearly
that's being useful to have something
which can work
when there is some defamation that's
right
it that that's not called i mean
yes it is it is useful
but that's not quite what these guys do
okay at this stage
i have fine but maybe that's what they
will do in the future and that's okay
but maybe not these ones but some other
thing that recognizes
yeah but find geometric transform does
the finds an approximate thing though
right like it doesn't care that they'd
be exactly right
but that's why it says they're fitting
it does it fitting
yes i know but so you can't have a
function called find geometric transform
and another one called find region
transform that do bizarrely similar but
different things
so we need a further discussion about
this yep yep
um
okay all right um
for those following these
live streams we will be continuing with
one about
uh video primarily right or did we
finish the video segment and now we now
into image processing
uh we have a little bit of video left
okay and we'll be back to that in five
minutes or so okay um